A fast food chain in Brazil is selling burgers
wrapped in edible paper. And hey, look, it's
Mr. T...BAG.
Vsauce, Kevin here. This is Mind Blow.
Researchers from Spain have developed this
eco-friendly brick. By using waste from paper
mills and mixing it with clay, they pressurize
and extrude it like a sausage to create these
paper building blocks. They take less time
in the kiln than conventional bricks, saving
energy and money, but they're currently not
quite as strong.
Meanwhile the Tokyo Metropolitan University
Graduate School of System Design is developing
virtual body technology that utilizes five
senses. Visuals are provided by a 3D monitor,
headphones for audio, it can create the feeling
of wind and spread smells with a fan, a chair
that leans back and forth and vibrates, and
it even has foot pedals. The idea is to allow
seniors to experience things like traveling
Milan, or running the 100-meter dash like
Usain Bolt.
Gate Feeder is a high-tech way to make sure
your proper cat gets the proper food. Only
the cat wearing the right RFID tag collar
can open the door preventing other cats who
might bully each other out of food, interrupting
regular meals or special diets.
World's Largest Round Pizza.
Roboy aims to be the most modern tendon-driven
robot in the world. The Artificial Intelligence
Lab of the Univeristy of Zurich is building
this open source humanoid service robot in
only 9 months, and they intend for Roboy to be helpful to humans. And hopefully
not destroy us...
Sound Bottle was designed by Jun Fujiwara
of Tama Art University to record the soundtrack
of everyday life. It makes a database of sound
sources and forms music with automatic repetitions.
It turns out belly buttons are like rain forests
of bacteria. A recent study found that from
60 belly buttons, 2,368 bacterial species
were found, 1,458 of which may be new to science.
So...Yeah.
Techjet's Robot Dragonfly is a palm-sized
robot that flies like a bird, hovers like
an insect, and is designed for aerial photography,
gaming, and security. This award winning,
WiFi enabled micro-flying insect has 20 environmental
sensors, GPS capabilities and HD cameras.
You can also customize color and even the
wing design. Find the link below for more.
"Honey, you're burning the ice cubes again!"
"It's just calcium carbide reacting with water
to form acetylene gas." "Alright."
Finally, Firewall is an interactive media
installation by Aaron Sherwood in which a
sheet of spandex acts as an interface to create
fire-like visuals and play music...
I'm gonna leave you with a robot that juggles
without any sensors and, as always, thanks
for watching.